the idea that you would go and support
and help our number one state sponsor of
terror around the world
but stab our friend israel in the back
is
as unconscionable as anything i can
imagine
i'm dave rubin and believe it or not
people i am live in studio
with a guest she is the former governor
of south carolina the former u.s
ambassador to the un the author
of the book right here in my hands right
now
and a real human being i can't believe
it nikki haley
thank you so much i mean first we just
got to do this part i mean we're sitting
just a few
feet away from each other i have not
done a live interview
in person since july my last one was ted
cruz
so you got to follow up ted cruz we'll
see how that goes
but just to sit with another person oh
it's so nice right
i mean we've been through a lot the
country's been through a lot but i think
the country can't wait to just be
open again and be moving and you know
start to live life again yeah
are you shocked how long it's been
i mean a year and a half later it was
two weeks to flatten the curve and here
we are
i mean i think if you had told us all
this was going to happen
you know prior to 20. nobody would have
believed it but to really
see all the forces at play you know the
fear
tactics the idea that they you know
keeping kids from school the masks the
you know just the over exaggeration of
everything i hope it's taught a lesson
which is look we all want to keep people
safe we all want to do our part
but there is a role that government has
and there's a role that government
doesn't and the idea that
that small businesses that we lost
thousands of them
through this the idea that people were
not allowed to make their own decisions
that's a real mistake and we shouldn't
let that happen again
so as a conservative do you think in a
weird way as terrible as this has all
been this has been the best
argument for sort of small government
policies that people are kind of waking
up
look we're here in l.a right now in
california you know my feelings about
this place
uh that that real world examples have
sort of led people i think
to fall more in the conservative bucket
look i think we have to see this for the
opportunity it is it was a reminder that
states should be able to control what
happens
you know in terms of laws we don't need
the federal government man dating down
states know their people best if you
look at you know whether it was georgia
when they were the first ones to open up
and people were screaming about it a
governor knows where their hot spots are
a governor knows
which areas they have to be careful of
so allowing governors to decide that but
if you look at the states that stayed
open
versus the states that closed down you
had more deaths in the states that
closed down
i mean there is something to personal
responsibility and when i was governor
i always thought when we had hurricanes
you you educate
you give people the facts then let them
make the best decision for them and
their families
government doesn't need to make that
decision for them and this was a real
lesson during covet of
you know there it does go too far and
when you watch the economy and what
we've been through and the number of
people
out of work and the small businesses
that have closed didn't have to happen
that way
yeah so you don't think that governors
should just pick arbitrary dates like
june 15th as gavin newsom who is now
being recalled should do
you don't think that was the best idea i
think it's pretty crazy i mean i i
really do i think that the idea that
well first of all i think he uh knows a
recall is on the way
right right right you think it has a
little something right needs to open up
yeah no i mean i think look people can
make good decisions i still believe in
the goodness of people i still believe
that they are perfectly capable of
knowing what's best for their children
and their families
and what they're willing to do and
government needs to just move out of the
way it's always been that way
and any i mean people have to remember
government breaks more than it fixes
always has what did ronald reagan say
the worst what was it the worst eight
words i'm going to slightly butcher it
i'm from the government and i'm here to
help you
pretty much that's where okay i know we
could do we could probably
do an hour and a half just on covet and
all that stuff but you sent out a tweet
yesterday in the midst of this
john kerry firestorm that is erupting
right now so i actually want to read the
tweet and then we'll give a little
context to what happened
uh you said this is disgusting on many
levels biden and kerry have to answer
what for why kerry
would be tipping off iran the number one
sponsor of terror
while stabbing one of our greatest
partners israel in the back
and what this is in reference to is
audio has leaked of the foreign
secretary of iran
basically saying that then secretary of
state john kerry told him about israeli
strikes
in syria this seems like a massive
scandal
but in the 24 hours since it got out
there like yeah the right
is talking about it but pretty much
nobody mainstream nobody on the left
but this seems big to me it is big i
mean biden and kerry have to answer for
this i mean this
is you know first of all if it's true
this he can't i mean it's leaked audio
of the foreign can't be in the national
security council he shouldn't be a
cabinet member biden should answer for
it kerry should answer
i happen to believe it and the reason i
happen to believe it is carrie and zarif
were very close they worked on the iran
deal together
obama and kerry never liked israel they
basically stabbed israel in the back
even
after the election was over and the u.n
at the security council
and so the idea that you would go and
support and help our number one state
sponsor of terror around the world
but stab our friend israel in the back
is
as unconscionable as anything i can
imagine but it's so
typical of the obama 2.0 it's so typical
and
i think it's dangerous and i don't trust
carrie i don't trust him
to not have done this i don't trust
biden to make carrie answer for it
and i think we still have to be loud
about it because this is not okay
what do you make generally of john kerry
because it seems like he's gotten
pretty much everything wrong forever
there's videos that go viral every now
and again
of just like all the things that he has
said that he has just predicted
to be wrong i mean i just think you know
he was the one that said peace in the
middle east would only happen
that went through the palestinians you
know he felt like that we had to be in
the iran deal because otherwise bad
things were happening yet
when i questioned him on it i said you
know
you knew that this deal wasn't going to
last long you knew that within 10 years
they'd be
um you know doing nuclear warheads again
and he said well yeah we just knew it
was a stall tactic well stalling is not
okay fixing is the way to do it and so
you know even if it's biden getting on
this electric bike you know after he
gets off his private plane it's just
hypocritical at best and that's why
i don't think we can trust him that's
why i think anything that he
gets involved in he's an elitist he's an
elitist liberal who thinks he knows
better than everybody else and talks
down to everyone
right well there's that that video of
when he was getting on his private jet
he said well i have important business
to do
that's why i can be on a private jet not
you peons you guys are all just doing
nothing right
it's just it's so hypocritical and it's
i mean the idea when we all heard john
kerry was going to be back
in the cabinet in the national security
council i think we all took a breath
back because we knew how much he wanted
that iran deal
and even though he supposedly you know
the climate envoy
he's going to always be weighing in on
all issues of iran that's why i think
biden needs to answer for it
this is really serious stuff but do you
think the media will do anything i mean
that that
partly you know i talk on the show all
the time now about that we're basically
just in this reality war
it's like half the people will see that
story and be like oh there's something
here
and then the other half just won't see
it and then it's like well now we're
just fighting over what's actually true
it's the reason nobody trusts media
anymore i mean why should you you're
getting one side of the story you go to
any cable network
and you're getting what they think you
know on one side or the other
what happened to the days where you just
gave us the facts and we decided what we
wanted to think
and i think the days of those are gone
so you'll never see cnn talking about
carrie doing this
you'll never see msnbc talking about it
and you know i think we still have to be
loud i think we have to push it but it's
the same thing with the border and kamal
at the border
yeah we can talk about how many days she
hasn't been there
but you know even though you know
they're uncomfortable with the situation
they won't say anything
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell